[Music]
Sooey thank you for being here thank you
for having me just a few weeks ago we
went on it we went to a beehive together
and now we're we have to do this over
zoom it crazy world it is it is crazy
world and you know I think that here we
are you are you know in quarantine I'm
in quarantine in today's date I think I
just want to put it in perspective over
a million people have now contracted the
corona virus around the world more than
50 thousand people died from it
the United States is leading in terms of
people that are contracting the virus
and there is a lot unknown situation of
how this is going to unravel and how
it's going to impact and I think that
we're already seeing our lives being
impacted and we're already saying that
so many people are suffering from this
both you know health-wise as well as
economic loss and this is really the
reality in which we're doing this
interview and so I'm happy to I'm happy
to talk about what we're doing and
episodes you know what I think you know
kind of we're heading into and and you
know the reality suck nobody knows you
know tuition okay so I'm already upset
that we only have a twenty minutes for
this discussion because I think weekly
for hours but but you know I have to I
do have to say that we are very
fortunate that that in the place we are
quarantined in and the facilities that
we have around us you know I have the
privilege of taking this little guy now
and raising him to be a mensch of a
mention of a dog and you know a lot of
people are suffering around the world
and I saw with we almost had I think
seven million people filed for
unemployment in the US and and now I
have the privilege of talking to one of
my favorite
capitalists and and I just want to hear
a first of all I want to hear about you
and and how did you even get to up West
what is sort of your mission and and
what's been happening now and and more
importantly what's happening now we're
in April of 2020 something that the
world really that this new world has
never really seen at this magnitude I
have to hear your take because to me
it's much more interesting than anything
else I hear on the news right now yeah
so I think that you know quickly about a
quest so we've been around for eight
years I started the fund together with
my amazing partner given Alex II love we
have we started our quest here in
Silicon Valley this is where we live but
you know for the last 20 years I've been
working on the Israel US tech Junction
spending a lot of time helping founders
break into the US market and finding
customers and growing businesses and
creating really global companies with up
West we felt that at the early stage
proceed and seed we can really create
impact for Israeli founders who are
heading to the US market and this is
what we've been doing for the last eight
years we've invested in over 80
companies they're raised you know over a
billion dollars some of them you know a
really category leaders in their own
domains and we've we've been fortunate
to kind of write the first check for
many of them and and help them scale and
build their businesses here in the US
surely one thing that I'm fascinated
about your we're here in Palo Alto and
and one of the one of the biggest goals
up until now has been to attract Israeli
founders and bring them here how do you
do it from here don't you have to be in
Israel for that so lucky for us is that
just like our companies of course is a
cross-border fund we have a team in
Israel and we have a teen year and you
know this whole situation today
or on a virus we realized you know
invested so many people because all of a
sudden they had to start working
remotely utilizing technology such as
zoom and slack and all these that's
something that we we've been doing for
years right we've been working remotely
for years and so as are many of our
entrepreneurs so our entrepreneurs you
know have have been working with
distributed teams engineering and Tel
Aviv business in the US for you know for
many years this is how they run their
businesses so the impact on many of them
and the impact on us has been really
kind of minimal because we've already
established these Cadence's of work so
what's happening on the greater scheme
of a venture capital and and startups
from your take from your point of view
so I can tell you that you know this is
you know as bad situation as it is you
know there are few things that I can
tell you I feel super fortunate about in
this situation number one is that we are
in California and we are in Silicon
Valley and I think a lot of people all
kind of love to criticize Silicon Valley
for being some sort of a bubble and
having kind of a detached view of the
world in many ways the optimists live
here and we all know that and I think
that you know so for many for many
reason I feel that every day you know I
I get up I see the news I'm really
depressed about it no but my my
conversations my one-on-one
conversations both with entrepreneurs
and with tech executives you know it
starts with the situation is really bad
and we've seen the economy kind of
ticking and die but very quickly it
turns into what's the opportunity where
are we going to build the next amazing
companies what are we going to create in
different categories how is this
impacted the lives of consumers having
this disaffected
enterprise's what kind of things now are
on the front burner of the typical CIO
of you know a big enterprise a
manufacturing side a hospital what are
they going to do right now and what is
really important for them and so having
these conversations on a daily basis is
really I think refreshing in light of
you know we're heading into what many
people think is a year-long you know
before we even going to start to get
back to normal
another reason I feel really fortunate
you know is that my my last two three
weeks have been 90 percent of
conversations have been with my own
portfolio companies and the
conversations are not easy because they
went from a mindset of growth and you
know hiring and you know aggressively
going after new markets to a place of
having to contract all that the place of
having to freeze hires to layoff people
to reduce the projections and the
milestones to having to deliver news you
know like that to their employees and
that is you know on one hand really
tough conversations to have on the other
hand I'm so inspired by how they've been
handling it and I'm so inspired because
the true strength of entrepreneurs come
out in times like this yeah these these
are the entrepreneurs who they take
action really quickly they assess the
situation really quickly they don't
pause they collect information from as
many people as possible and the most
important thing is and I think that this
is number one thing that I really want
many founders to understand is your
communication skills in times like this
is the most simple
how frequently are you communicating
with your employees customers and
investors and how do you communicate and
that's what I seen the last two weeks in
many of the founders that we've been
working with and in our portfolio CEOs
and that's what gives me I think a lot
of a lot of hope and a lot of confidence
and and I think the sense of a sense of
pride in what we're doing on a daily
basis so you know it's really I can't
help but I go on I go on my feed both on
LinkedIn and Facebook and I see a lot of
people quoting you know 2008 gave birth
to to so many unicorns and so many VCS
are while a lot of VCS are sort of
closing doors closing their door and
saying see you in 2021 a lot of them are
saying let's double down on our
investment let's let's use these
opportunities and I you have a pretty
interesting take on that so so what's
what why is there such a big discrepancy
on the two extremes if you look at you
know if you look at the previous
recessions and you know I think I'm old
enough that I that I have experienced
both 2000 and 2008 actually 2008 I was
an operator I you know I was running an
organization I had to lay off staff I
had to deliver my board the news of were
totally changing directions and we cut
we cut salaries to everybody and well
and had to we had to just totally
rearrange everything that we've done and
I think that's what will happen here as
well it will happen here for fat for for
startups it will happen you for
enterprises it will happen here for
everybody people will have to just
completely adjust a new reality I think
that what I've seen in previous
recession is it took about two years for
things to kind of you know slowly come
back to a situation where people are
excited
about investing or having confidence in
certain sectors we have a lot of
conversations right now between us when
I talk to colleagues in the venture
capitals you know world here in Silicon
Valley we have a lot of conversations
with each other on you know where do you
think you know the next you know growth
will be in the economy what are we
seeing in digital health what are we
seeing in online education what are we
seeing and if actually what are we
seeing and cloud infrastructure and
cybersecurity all these areas that we
know Automation these are areas that we
know that will not take a big hit right
now actually there actually are the kind
of solutions that people would want to
see your continued so there's a lot of
conversations and people assessing
situations in various industries
obviously some industries have taking a
big hit Travel Lost battalion
construction real estate all runs but I
think we're too early in the process to
really understand the extent how this
will even impact you know the typical
tech companies even tech companies that
are now doing sorry but I have to ask
you I mean people is this a time when
people are gonna sit back and reflect
and and sort of assess whether they're
doing the right thing and are we gonna
see a spark of innovation as a result of
this that when things do get better
people are gonna be more critical of
themselves they're gonna have more time
to talk to their to their employees and
customers because they sort of stopped
running forward and they just took some
time out to think yeah I mean I think
that a lot of people are in right now
you know as I mentioned entrepreneurs
strong entrepreneurial do you know extra
communication right now with their
customers and when you when you we need
two extra communication with your
customers
many of them are now available to talk
to you learn about their pain you learn
about you know what is the underlying
pain that they have that is maybe
different in times like this that in now
enables you to adjust your your your
product you know adjust your what's
prioritizing you know right now in terms
of what you but developing versus what
you've developed up until now so I think
that listening to customers right now is
what you need to do we will see
incredible innovation in times like this
we will see people that are being super
creative and how they are approaching
their markets we're going to see
entrepreneurs that you know that are
then are really coming out of this
really terrible times helping a lot of
industries to digitize just think about
that think about how many people when to
work from home
all of a sudden realizing they don't
have the right infrastructure to run
their operations
how many enterprises don't even have
cloud infrastructure that allows to have
their work from home how many of them
are concerned about privacy in
cybersecurity and all of those things in
times like this when hundreds of their
employees are working from home what
about education I mean you're a student
at Stanford look at that how many
schools elementary schools and high
schools don't have the infrastructure to
offer instruction remotely so we're
going to see so much you know so many
solutions that are targeting these kinds
of situations and and I think you know
that's kind of the excitement and I
think that that we can have in times
like this as horrible as it is right now
so from from your standpoint when you're
you're thinking okay I'm we're gonna get
back into things and we're gonna open
our doors again do you already have some
idea of
types of companies you're looking to see
or what types of of industries you're
looking to invest in and has this
changed there as a result of Corona or
are things going to shift more to
different industries and I can tell you
you know it up west we've been super
focused on having very diverse portfolio
you know a lot of companies yeah Company
B to e commerce I mean all across the
board so so I don't you know I don't
foresee a lot of change for us because
we've been very Enterprise focused type
of investors less consumers less you
know real estate and things like that I
think that most of our most amount of
invested investments have been in
providing solutions you know in the
cloud you know taking AI in two
different areas and having companies
that providing that both to
manufacturing as well as energy as well
as different item industries
agricultural technologies as you know
IOT things like that and I you know
obviously we've always been with our
ears to the ground on on what's
percolating and I think we're gonna
continue to do that we are we just have
a policy of talking to everyone right so
we we see about a thousand you know
startups a year and we have a policy of
seeing everyone talking to everyone we
have a team in Israel you met Leah and
in an incredible energy and and between
us you know on our team we have the
privilege of really seeing founders that
are now thinking about you know what
should I work on and what are the things
that in the market are going to be you
know
acting in technologies what areas in the
market will be open to you know try a
pilot really you know in my small
company so so I think that we're not
going to do much adjustment in terms of
our areas of focus but as I mentioned
areas there earlier there are few areas
that definitely will take a lot more
opportunity than others and we're
watching these areas just like everyone
else do you feelings in some way a sense
of responsibility as one of the people
that fuel this innovation and this and
this tech industry because you are I
mean that's you're on the side that
really fuels it financially speaking yes
I mean I think that the number one thing
is like we've seen we've seen in our
work is is thinking about solutions that
number one have ability to to impact
certain industries and the effect is
important on many levels but in a sense
of you know will this be a good impact
we've done a few investments in in
healthcare technologies in the last year
we started to see entrepreneurs in
Israel really you know thinking about
this space a lot and providing a lot of
great new technologies whether it's
patients monitoring which we all know
now is like the most important thing as
well as how do we really create an
environment within the hospital to be
able to process data and share it with
research and these are the two things
that I think that we seem now in
coronavirus times how much it's really
important to invest in things like that
and and I think that we're gonna we're
gonna see more and more of investors and
VC's thinking more about the kind of
thing
once they wanna make because of what
where we are today
because we know that there are many
industries that are not efficient that
are not providing the services and the
care that they need to look at our food
supply look at our life chain that is
broken so I think there are many
opportunities in these areas and then
you know we can't wait to talk to you
know smart founders who believe that you
know this is what they want to disrupt
definitely well I'm very hopeful that
one day I can be one of those founders
and comment and come pick steel myself
before we leave surely I need three
words that describe you sorry to put you
on the spot but that's how we do it oh
my god three words that describe me I
would say I'm an optimist all right I
would say um you know I'm extremely
persistent there you go a thousand
companies a year yeah that's persistence
and I'm curious I love it truly thank
you so much for taking the time for this
thank you for having me can't wait for
the next one
beautiful